ja und auf den ukraine krieg und die
auswirkungen schauen wir jetzt den
ganzen morgen mit der sicherheits
expertin der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik claudia meyer joachim guten tag
guten morgen wir haben gehört die eu
plant eine schnelle eingreiftruppe
die verteidigungsministerin sagt das
herzstück soll sozusagen aus deutschland
kommen in weit ist denn die bundeswehr
bereit das zu schaffen auch für die
bundeswehr ist das eine herausforderung
das wissen wir weil sie einfach in den
vergangenen jahren zusammen gespart
worden ist wenig modernisiert worden ist
und auch relativ wenig politische
beachtung bekommen hat das hat sich
jetzt verändert mit dem krieg in der
ukraine und auch mit den neuen
finanzzusagen
aber wir müssen auch anerkennen dass die
gab versäumnisse der letzten jahre sich
nicht einfach so wegwischen lassen das
heißt es ist politisch ein super gutes
signal ist aber auch schon vorher
entschieden worden ist jetzt noch mal
wiederholt worden aber wird eine große
herausforderung sein sie sagen ein super
gutes signal welches signal sendet die
eu richtung russland das nächste signal
gegenüber russland sondern das ist
generell ein signal dass die eu
international aktiver sein möchte denn
was gestern entschieden wurde ist einmal
der sogenannte strategische compass das
ist so eine art militär strategie der eu
an der die eu zwei jahre lang gearbeitet
hat und diese idee der schnellen
eingreiftruppe das ist also nicht so
sehr russland spezifisch oder eine
längere planung dass die eu
international mehr ihre interessen
durchsetzen will also ich würde nicht so
sehr auf russland beziehen schauen wir
auf die ukraine und den krieg dort man
hat so ein bisschen das gefühl russland
stoppt so ein bisschen mit dem vormarsch
welchen eindruck haben sie in der tat
haben wir denn jetzt gerade den eindruck
dass die front verläuft relativ stabil
sind dass ich da nicht so richtig was
bewegt wir sehen allerdings auch dass
ich bei den friedensverhandlungen nicht
so richtig was bewegt und wir sehen
drittens dass russland an seinen zielen
aber festhält also wir sehen weiterhin
sehr rücksichtslos und sehr brutales
vorgehen die frage ist was jetzt kommt
haben wir entweder eine gruppierung der
kräfte also dass sich russland neu
aufstellt oder haben wir so eine art
stellungs und zermürbungskrieg wo die
städte und belagert werden und die sich
da geradezu ein graben das sind so ein
bisschen die beiden optionen die man
sich vorstellen kann die gruppierung
oder tatsächlich so eine art am wirkungs
und stellungskrieg was halten sie für
realistischer die sind zermürbung
stellungskrieg
momentan sieht das so aus als würde das
eher in die richtung gehen eher so eine
art wirklich vermögen kaputtmachen und
belagern sie haben gesagt russland hält
an seinen zielen bisher fest ein ziel
ist ja quasi die ukraine so ein bisschen
zu einem verbalen staat zu machen sehen
sie denn dass putin diesem ziel auch
noch näher kommen kann momentan momentan
scheint der fokus sehr stark auf
wirklich dass die zerstörung der
infrastruktur und das vermögen zu liegen
also wir sehen immer noch diese extrem
rücksichtslosen angriffe auf städte die
zerstörung von ziviler infrastruktur die
angriffe auf zivilisten auch die
angriffe auf flüchtlings
korridore das heißt vor dem
übergeordneten ziel die ukraine zu
kontrollieren rückte er nicht ab aber
momentan scheint focus wirklich mehr auf
zermürben und zerstören zu geben
möglicherweise auch um die ukraine in so
ein diktat frieden rhein zu pressen und
zu sagen das land wird so zerstört kommt
so unter angriff dass sich die regierung
möglicherweise gezwungen fühlt so ein
russischen diktat frieden zuzustimmen
bisher sehen wir das ja nicht von
ukrainischer seite da heißt dass
kapitulation die ist nicht ist
ausgeschlossen quasi wir sehen aber das
haben sie auch gesagt viel zerstörung
viel menschliches leid die frage ist so
ein bisschen der druck auf die nato
unter umständen wächst auch dort unter
umständen eben doch einzugreifen also
die frage was für möglichkeiten hat die
nato noch unterhalb einer
flugverbotszone die ja bedeuten würde
wirklich eintritt in den krieg
wenn man sich momentan die nato debatte
anguckt bleibt es relativ klar erste
aufgabe der nato schutz der eigenen
alliierten
also alles verstärkung der ostflanke
mehr verteidigungsbereitschaft und so
also schutz der eigenen staaten und
danach bleibt es meines erachtens bei
der roten linie zu sagen wir
unterstützen so viel wie es geht
einzelne staaten unterstützen sehr viel
die usa haben ein neues militärisches
unterstützungspaket aufgelegt aber kein
eingreifen und dazwischen sehe ich
gerade nicht sehr viel also ich glaube
es bleibt wirklich bei der
traditionellen linie unterstützt und so
weit wie es geht aber kein direktes
eingreifen um einen direkten krieg mit
russland zu verhindern auch nicht wenn
chemiewaffen beispielsweise eingesetzt
würden das ist eine frage die gerade
sehr viel diskutiert wird weil das
natürlich noch mal ein weiterer völker
rechtsbruch und nochmal eine weitere
rote linie wäre momentan sieht es so aus
als würde es an dem großen kalkül nichts
ändern ein eingriff der nato direkt in
der ukraine könnte einen krieg mit
russland nach sich ziehen und das will
die nato vermeiden vielen dank frau
major für ihre einschätzung claudia
major von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik wir werden den ganzen morgen
noch mit ihr weiter sprechen vielen dank
erstmal ein bisschen hin kerner und wir
wollen uns das ganze jetzt noch ein
bisschen einordnen lassen von claudia
major sicherheits expertin der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik erneut unser
gast schönen guten morgen & morgen also
es wird wir haben schon ein paar mal
gesagt auf der einen seite geschossen
getötet gekämpft und auf der anderen
seite wird schon auch verhandelt wir
haben es gerade gehört herz angesprochen
seelands gerd angekündigt sollte es
irgendwann mal zu irgend einer lösung
kommen dann möchte er das volk darüber
abstimmen lassen das problem ist bloß
dass putin sich aktuell einem gespräch
mit ihm verweigert und lieber seinen
geschichtspolitischen berater schickt
warum verweigert sich putin weil er dann
theoretisch sagen würde okay ich erkenne
ihn doch noch als präsidenten an putin
hat ja ganz klar gemacht dass er der
ukraine eigene identität abspricht sie
gar nicht anerkennt und immer gesagt das
gehört zu russland das heißt wenn er
sich jetzt mit dem präsidenten treffen
würde würde er irgendwie anerkennen dass
die ukraine doch ein eigenständiges land
ist was wichtig ist es dass russland
seine ziele nicht erreicht hat also die
schnelle kontrolle über die ukraine aber
von diesen zielen nicht abweicht bislang
hat russland kein ernsthaftes interesse
an verhandlungen gezeigt sondern
verfolgt die ziele in dem edith
arisierung also das land de facto die
infrastruktur kaputt zu machen
entnazifizierung also die eliten
auszutauschen neutraler status war folgt
es weiter das heißt das müssen wir ganz
klar sagen ziele bislang nicht erreicht
von russland aber es verlässt diese
ziele nicht aus hält daran fest und am
ende sagt putin wahrscheinlich neuer wir
haben ja versucht zu verhandeln aber
kirche stur und dann sind wir einfach
mit dafür verantwortlich dass der krieg
weitergeht ich habe jetzt deswegen
vielleicht noch mal die art der
kriegsführung auch an der gestern hat
die usa haben die usa ja noch mal vor
einem einsatz von einem russischen
angriff mit chemiewaffen gewarnt wie
schätzen sie das ein was wir jetzt sehen
ist noch mal diese diese idee sie haben
die kriegsziele nicht erreicht halten
aber unbedingt daran fest und das führt
zu einem immer rücksichtsloser im krieg
wir sind es mit der bombardierung der
städte
ohne rücksicht auf zivilisten ohne
rücksicht auf humanitäre fragen und
damit steigt auch das risiko dass
schmutzige bomben eingesetzt werden oder
dass chemie waffen eingesetzt werden
einfach weil dieses ziel die ukraine zu
kontrollieren so rücksichtslos verfolgt
wird und deswegen ist glaube ich die
drohungen der usa sehr ernst zu nehmen
weil russland von dem ziel nicht abrückt
sondern er sagt wir versuchen es um
jeden preis deshalb ist das eine sehr
beunruhigende aber auch eine sehr
ernstzunehmende drohung und alle welt
fragt sich natürlich wie kann man die
ukraine weiterhin unterstützen also im
moment gibt es waffen es gibt geld um
wiederum waffen zu kaufen
aufnahme von geflüchteten und einiges
mehr aber vielmehr scheint nicht machbar
zu sein weil niemand diesen atomaren
krieg natürlich führen möchte sehen sie
aber doch noch vielleicht ein zwei
puzzleteile wo sie sagen dass da ist
luft ein fenster für die europäische
union oder die weltgemeinschaft das ist
unheimlich schwer weil es immer diese
rote linie ist wie kann man ein maximum
unterstützen ohne selbst rein gezogen zu
werden und sowohl die eu als auch die
einzelnen staaten haben diesen raum
eigentlich ausgereizt was sind wir
eigentlich darf ich das nochmal sind
finde ich eigentlich schon in dem wir
waffen liefern indem wir jetzt sagen wir
geben der ukraine noch mal geld damit
sie dann waffen kauft aus der
europäischen union sind wir nicht
eigentlich schon teil der x4 selber teil
wir sind teile und aus russischer
perspektive sind wir schon lange teil
sie haben die wirtschaftssanktionen und
die anderen entscheidungen sieht
russland als konflikt als aggression als
provokation an die interessante frage
für mich und auf die ich sage ich ganz
ehrlich keine antwort habe ist was wäre
wenn es wirklich zu einem chemiewaffen
angriff käme was wäre wenn es zum
biologischen angriff mit biologischen
waffen käme was wäre wenn diese weitere
rote linie sind ja schon viel geboten
die niederlassen wollen will syriens
genau was wäre was wäre dann ob sich
dann möglicherweise die linie der
westlichen staaten verschiebt
andererseits bleibt ja diese unheimlich
schwierige frage wir wollen unterstützen
aber eine direkte intervention könnte
noch dazu viel größeren katastrophe und
dem direkten kriegsfall führen diese
schwierige abwägung bleibt ja vielleicht
schauen wir uns in diesem zusammenhang
auch noch einmal die rolle von china an
die ja auch ganz ganz wichtige rolle
oder entscheidende rolle möglicherweise
spielen können muss china sich jetzt
nicht an dieser stelle auch entscheiden
auf wessen seite sie quasi stehen also
wie lange
wir werden die sich positionieren china
hat sehr stark versucht so eine balance
zu finden und sich nicht ganz klar zu
bekennen es gibt diesen alten spruch
zwischen russland und china die
beziehung heißt nicht immer miteinander
aber nie gegeneinander
wahrscheinlich ist der chinesische
präsident der einzige der einfluss auf
den russischen präsidenten hat hat sich
aber bislang entschieden diesen einfluss
nicht geltend zu machen ob das
irgendwann kippt hängt enorm davon ab
wie der krieg weiter geht momentan
scheint die russische strategie zu sein
entweder die ukraine so zu zermürben
dass sie einen diktat frieden letztlich
irgendwann zustimmen müssen oder den
ukrainischen präsidenten so zu
stabilisieren dass er sich irgendwann
nicht mehr halten kann diktat frieden
wieder was gelernt schlimmes wort
claudia major vielen dank für die
einordnung und einschätzungen gesehen
uns diese woche noch mal wieder danke
für ihre zeit sicherheits expertin der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik